hey what's up everyone it's Warren super
exciting stuff to talk about today as
soon as we heard that Captain Marvel was
going to feature the kree-skrull war we
all started to think Secret Invasion
could we get a Secret Invasion movie or
movies in the MCU well it's actually
looking that that could be a very good
possibility and this is coming directly
from Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios in a recent interview about
Captain Marvel he was asked about the
possibility for a Secret Invasion in the
MCU so in this video I'll break down
everything he said and what it could
possibly mean for the future quick
reminder about my giveaway if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win five
imax tickets all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain big spoiler alert if you have
not seen Captain Marvel yet if you do
not want anything spoiled for Captain
Marvel click away now
so Secret Invasion could it come to the
MCU since it turns out that the scroll
are good in Captain Marvel and not bad
as we know them in the comics people are
saying well there's no possibility for
Secret Invasion now since the scroll are
good but according to Kevin Feige that
is not the case in an interview for
Captain Marvel he was asked if there
could still be a Secret Invasion even
though the scroll are good now and this
is what he said I think like the Kree
and like humanity there are good scrolls
and there are bad scrolls but one of the
things we wanted to do in this movie is
you know don't judge a book by its cover
and tap into people's preconceived
notions of the pointy-eared green aliens
being evil and subverting that but I do
think to continue fleshing them out and
making them these three-dimensional
actual beings the scrolls you would
encounter good ones and bad ones so
basically what he's saying is that for
Captain Marvel he wanted to do a
different take on the scrolls making
them good however just like the Kree and
just like humanity there are good people
and there are bad people there are good
scrolls and there are bad scrolls and
what he's saying is that if they
continue to make these movies with the
scroll they will eventually encounter
evil ones so yes Secret Invasion could
still happen even though the scroll are
good in Captain Marvel and like talo
said and Captain Marvel there are
thousands of scroll in the universe
so you can definitely bet that some of
them will be bad and not good so it's
definitely a possibility for Secret
Invasion The Secret Invasion story is
awesome and it has so many heroes in it
it's after the kree-skrull war and it
has Ironman mr. fantastic name Moore
Black Bolt Professor X and Doctor
Strange joined together as the
Illuminati and it has other characters
such as Thor daredevil The Young
Avengers the Thunderbolts so many
awesome people in one story it's
something that I think everybody would
love to see play out especially after
the Disney Fox deal and Disney can now
use all these characters and thankfully
even though the scroll are good and
Captain Marvel it still seems like
there's a possibility for Secret
Invasion to happen in the MCU and it
sounds like Kevin Feige has thought
about it which makes sense because again
we have a lot of characters returning
home to Disney and Marvel that we can
now use in the MCU so really good news
Secret Invasion could happen in the MCU
coming from Kevin Feige president of
Marvel Studios himself so let me know
what you think about this news would you
be excited to see Secret Invasion
in the MCU let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment down below
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel and
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fluff
[Music]
you